there was a time before april of 2020
when
port-au-pic nova scotia was known simply
as a quiet safe nova scotia community
where
not much happened and there was a time
when the rcmp was seen as a brave and
dependable force
an enduring symbol of strength famous
around the world
the mounties known for their red surge
uniforms and for always getting their
man
much of that was a romantic notion
poor depict now joins places like
moncton new brunswick
and mayor thorpe alberta places
synonymous with crisis and tragedy
including for the rcmp those mass
killings resulted in many injuries but
little change there is a need
for a lot of work moving forward to
improve and reform the rcmp so
how did we get here well the mounties
may be the only police force in the
world whose wikipedia entry states
they have an unusually large breadth of
duties
they enforce federal laws fight
organized crime
provide domestic and counter-terrorism
security as well as protective services
for vips
they also deliver police services at the
federal provincial and
municipal level they are the second
biggest police force in north america
but compared with other forces here in
canada they are underpaid
understaffed and overworked so
is there a way to fix it gary clement
has some ideas
he's one of the leading authorities on
policing in this country
he now runs a private investigative
agency focused on white-collar crime
after spending three decades with the
rcmp retiring at the rank of
superintendent
we talked to him from his home outside
ottawa
gary the whole country was horrified by
what happened in nova scotia not just
the murders
of course but the police response as a
former
cop yourself what was your gut reaction
well
at the outset i mean and i want to
preface this by saying it's really easy
to play
armchair quarterback after the fact but
all that being said
my my initial reaction is what you need
to have
after in a catastrophic event like this
uh is leadership and you need to have
people that get in front of the camera
and provide that sense of calm to the
community
and if i was to give points for the rcmp
on that initial
they failed miserably it is interesting
what you say about the media i'm sure
you've heard this from other reporters
is that
in terms of us dealing with the rcmp
it's basically uh
you know it's like hitting your head
against a brick wall often you just
don't get any information
and the kind of joke is that if you if
there's anything happening near the
border and you want to find out what's
happening you go ask the fbi because
they'll tell you
i made it a suggestion when i was
i think i at that time was an inspector
that we should look at hiring a
a journalist that was well known to
really lead us
because it was recognized years ago down
and the rcmp was doing a terrible job
this is just one of the symptoms of the
problems with the rcmp
if we were to look at what happens in
the united states
what you see is the leadership gets out
in front of these situations
they address it they give the public
some confidence
and there's all this secrecy wrapped
around it creates
uh confusion adds that there's a lot of
questions
raises the concerns of a major cover-up
when
9 10's out of 10 that's not the case but
the rcmp brings it on themselves
there is a chronic shortage of rcmp
officers in that region
and in other areas of canada too do you
think that potentially played a role in
the response
absolutely there's been a systemic
failure in the part of governments
to properly fund the rcmp and all of its
uh
requirements to for enforcement measures
is it time for the rcmp to get out of
municipal and provincial policing my
view is it's
it's long overdue and i say this just
because
um we and and i used reference
without going too far off topic donna
but
if we look at what's happened and what
the findings are in the cullen
commission
we're becoming a laughingstock when it
comes to traditional organized crime and
our ability to shut it down
when it comes to money laundering and
that really is the jurisdiction of the
rcmp but it's being pulled in so many
directions
that my view as the rcmp today is in a
crisis and
it's time that we accept that and the
government does something
to make sure that we keep the citizens
of canada safe
you know the circumstances in puerto
pick the horrible crimes
the gunmen committed were unlike
anything
we'd seen in canada have we learned from
that
now do you think would a response be
different
if something so horrific was to happen
again today i
without a doubt i mean i'm sure there's
a lot of
rcmp management that are beating
themselves up over this this isn't
something that you
just shun off and say you know nothing's
going to change i mean
the rcmp is having a hard look at it but
again i've got to go back donna that
we got to realize the rcmp cannot be all
things to all people and if we're going
to be more effective
we really should be honest with
ourselves recognize that
maybe it's time that we let provincial
and municipal
governments have deal with the policing
issue in their own backyard
and let the rcmp deal with the federal
very much like fbi or the drug
enforcement administration
united states so they they can be more
effective
and at the same time support our
provincial
and municipal partners because they look
to the rcmp to take on these higher
level investigations
and sadly they're failing miserably
right now